so if I want to save money I have to
find a family if I carry the one and
subtract this I save money
no I lose money for the last week I've
been trying to figure out these new
phone upgrade plans from the cellular
carriers that let you upgrade your phone
not at two years but at a year or even
six months sounds great
I know but it's not very economical and
it's really complicated usually we can
get a new phone every two years take the
iPhone 5s it cost six hundred and fifty
dollars but most carriers let you pay
one hundred and ninety nine with a
two-year contract you pay off the rest
of the costs and charges baked into your
high monthly service fees with these new
upgrade plans from AT&T t-mobile Sprint
and Verizon you pay down the cost of the
phone in monthly installments and you
pay the service fee then when you paid
half the phone off usually at about a
year mark you get a new phone sounds
great except I crunch the numbers and
you actually end up paying more about
two hundred and three hundred dollars
more for two years it gets worse if you
don't upgrade at exactly the one-year
mark you keep paying the carrier towards
that phone with all these plans you're
taking a bet than at a year there's a
phone you're going to want to upgrade to
and then when you do upgrade you don't
actually get to keep the phone you trade
it in so essentially you're paying more
money for a phone you don't own and the
carriers can just turn around and sell
it again speaking of you stand to
actually make more money if you bought
the phone at six hundred and fifty
dollars and then sold it a year later on
eBay or Glide but honestly I think the
worst part of all this is how
complicated the carriers have made these
plans
it's beyond aggravating to figure out if
you're losing or saving money t-mobile
seems to have the best deal but I'm
still not sure it's worth it if I were
you I'd hold on to your phone another
year longer instead of dealing with all
this